admis pro dans le centre du pays
l'hôpital fonctionne dans le noir depuis
que la ville a été bombardée la semaine
dernière venue apporter un groupe
électrogène le directeur européen de
l'OMS a renouvelé son soutien aux
personnel médical au moment où les
bombardements redoublent dans le pays
en tant que médecin je suis tellement
triste et indigné de voir que ces
attaques contre les établissements de
santé se poursuivent à ce jour l'OMS a
comptabilisé plus de 700 attaques contre
les structures de santé
il s'agit d'une violation très claire du
droit international
mercredi un bébé de deux jours a été tué
dans le bombardement d'une maternité à
vilniansk près de la ligne de front
versa porriggia des bombardements
qualifiés de crimes contre l'humanité
par le président ukrainien devant le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
volody mirzelenski a exigé des mesures
pour mettre fin à ses frappes russes
nous attendons une réaction ferme du
monde face à la terreur russe qui sévit
actuellement nous attendons une réponse
de nos partenaires
les frappes russes de ces derniers jours
ont fait plusieurs morts et entraîner
des coupures massives d'électricité et
d'eau notamment dans la capitale Kiev
une stratégie de la part du président
russe selon Washington
il semble que Poutine soit déterminée à
réduire en miettes les installations
énergétiques de l'Ukraine le motif de
Poutine ne pourrait être plus clair et
plus cruel il est clairement clairement
en train d'utiliser l'hiver à des fins
militaires pour infliger d'immense
souffrance au peuple craignant
pour l'aider à faire face les États-Unis
ont annoncé une nouvelle aide militaire
de 400 millions de dollars à l'Ukraine